Turning now to the front lines
in eastern Ukraine
where the bloody Russian advance
is forcing so many civilians to evacuate.
CNN's senior international correspondent
Sam Kiley has our report.
From a town many fear
could be Vladimir Putin's next target
A year into Russia's invasion,
this monochrome
misery is all too familiar.
This is what happened
just three days ago.
Here in Geneva, an S-300 missile strike.
Now, that's a missile
used by the Russians
for ground attack was actually designed
for bringing down airplanes,
but it carries a massive warhead.
It's pretty inaccurate.
And that doesn't matter to the Russians
because this is all about smashing up
the villages and towns
ahead of what the Ukrainians fear
is going to be a major Russian push
in this part of the country.
Captured on the
second day of Vladimir Putin's invasion
last February.
This is no longer a town
that scares easily.
It was liberated by Ukraine in the fall
and is within mortar
range of Russian troops today.
Yet these teenagers are taking a walk
through what remains of their village.
Why do your parents not insist
that you all leave as a family?
My dad has a farm here.
He's got land
and we can't just leave it all behind,
she says.
Across the
So we just don't want to go yet.
Well, if it gets serious,
then we'll leave it at the Jeep
attacking you.
And how would you define really serious?
In most countries?
Having a missile
that big land in the middle of town
is already really serious.
No water serious.
And it's actually
very serious
is probably
when a lot of houses are destroyed
and civilians suffer, she explains.
That is that you?
It's the defiance of
Ukrainian civilians
that Russia is trying to crush.
Putin's rockets and artillery
have rained down on towns
from Kherson to Kramatorsk
to Cookie, UNSC
and the northern border
with Russia
along a front line of 1300 kilometers.
That's 800 miles
this latest assault on her son,
another example
of the indiscriminate
shelling of civilians.
This isn't accidental.
It's deliberate.
The areas liberated by Ukraine bear
the brunt of an ever
increasing level of attacks by Russia.
Here in co-pilot's province,
as in her son.
Civilians survive on aid rations.
The mother who said
we don't know what to do,
she says houses are shaking.
Missiles are flying.
We just don't know what to wait for
was shaking like chickens.
We don't know what to expect.
Gruesome stuff So far, the
fighting has been most intense in
and around
parliament with a surge in attacks
by Russia on nearby villages.
In a foretaste
of the anticipated offensive
Veterans
like Alex, who captured this tank
called Bunny
from Russia
last March,
are running low on ammunition.
He says that he
sometimes is in combat
with only ten shells a day.
It's really hard.
We have a lot of casualties every day.
And the problem is that
the fighting moved inside the city
because like we are fighting
like building to building
and the distance is like 25 to 60 meters.
So we cannot use artillery.
Well here.
Civilians place their faith
in Ukraine's forces
to hold off the Russians
and play their part by staying on
and staying alive.
Now, Wolf,
according to the local authorities
in Kazan,
at least
six people were killed,
more than a dozen
injured in the use of multiple rocket
launching systems
and indiscriminate weapon.
Clearly intending to try to terrify
the civilian population,
as we say in that report,
the civilian population by
and large in
this country is remaining
incredibly resolute
after 12 months
of agony, of war, of murder,
of shortages,
of mass
movements, of refugees,
and in many cities,
particularly places
in the east, like Kharkiv,
where I am
now, or Kramatorsk
The population is actually beginning
to return to something
approaching normal, particularly
because the Russians were pushed back
from those gains
they made
in the early stages of the war Wolf.
Sam Kiley reporting for us.
Stay safe over there.
Thank you very, very much.